[Music]
welcome to nuke gaming Network I had a
request on one of my videos to show the
dark zone farming route that I use I
actually don't use one I have three I
mix them up depending on the server and
who else is farming the area most of the
time than farming on my own so these
work well when running solo but
obviously they've even faster with a
group these are pretty much the same
farming roots I've been using since 1.1
most of the rogue groups would run down
in DZ 1 and DZ 2 so I could spend hours
farming DZ for 2 DZ 6 without seeing a
single player with the expansion of the
dark zone not much has changed you can
run these paths without shooting a
bullet if that's what you want you may
just need to avoid a couple of the named
boss areas but you'll see that the
majority of the chests I collect are the
unguarded gold sealed cash chests with
these you can get a hell of a lot of
division tech and dark zone credits each
of the routes will have more items drop
then you're able to carry for a single
extraction so you can be picking with
what you choose to take once you get
familiar with the run you should be able
to fill your stash every twenty to
thirty minutes or so probably the only
area you'll be at risk as the extraction
areas if it doesn't feel right move on
to a different one we all have our
extraction points that we prefer to use
mine is DZ 4 it's out of the way and no
one really seems to go there if I see
anyone it's usually just another solo
player I'll show you a sped up version
of each run now but I've included a map
at the end of the video if you'd like to
skip to that I've included a link in the
description below otherwise if you found
this useful please leave a like and I'll
see you in the next video thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]